[Musique]
m
dans cette campagne seul souci c'est de
permettre le rassemblement
le pays ne va pas rien en particulier
parce que le gestion du pouvoir actuel
était une gestion se libère art brut
péremptoire
la force n'est pas grande copé les
seules terres et n'est pas forte si
l'écart augmente
je suis déterminé à être le président
d'une france réconciliée
le respecterai les français et je ferai
respecter la france
je dirais qu'il ya un car d'une certaine
france qui me plaît bien c'est à dire
une france qui est calme qui est sereine
avoir un candidat qui est resté dans
notre famille politique c'est très
important les militants ça leur fait
chaud au coeur
michel barnier c'est l'expérience le
plus beau cv la république il reste
ouvert aux idées neuves que nous les
jeunes on peut lui apporter
je crois au projet je crois en l'homme
et je suis prêt aujourd'hui à donner
de scolarité pour qu'ils puissent gagner
jusqu'à près un an scolarité ça se
rattrape cinq ans emmanuel macron ça se
rattrape mois quand même
[Musique]